you said there's the interesting thing
about mating strategies is there's a
small
pool of desirable mates
and what the word desirable means
is socially defined almost by on purpose
to make sure the pool always stays small
i would have a couple thoughts on that
now it's an interesting
issue set of issues you raise okay one
is that
um
we i think we have evolved adaptations
part of our psychology is to detect
differences
um and so this is why
um like a i don't know a a martian or an
alien coming down
they might look at humans and say boy
they all look alike as one just like we
look at i don't know zebras or whatever
we think they all look look alike
but
what's important in decision making
especially in the mating domain or even
friendship domain or or coalitional
selection domain is the differences
and and so i noticed this just a
concrete example of this um
uh i was sitting around this is again
ages ago uh
watching a uh a a something like a miss
america beauty contest and
people in there with a bunch of other
people and they were saying
boy did you see miss north carolina what
a dog and and so yeah this is
astonishing so here are like a 50
contestants who were selected as the
most attractive in their state
presumably um already they claim it's
based on talent um but um but we noticed
the differences
um and and and
uh and this is why i would push back a
little bit on the term socially
constructed because i think it's
um
there are many different
meanings of that of that phrase and
one meaning
that some people have one connotation is
that it's arbitrary and i don't think
it's arbitrary so
uh this has been another shift in
understanding
standards of beauty where it used to be
believed in the in the social sciences
you can't judge a book by its cover
beauty beauty's only the skin deep
you know don't judge people on the
superficial characteristics
but in fact physical appearance provides
a wealth of information
about the health status of someone there
in the case of males their physical
formidability
and we have formidability assessment
adaptations and then fertility as well
so there are
a very predictable set of cues to
fertility that have evolved to be part
of our
standards of attractiveness and and
they're not arbitrary there are some
culturally arbitrary ones so like
you go to the the maori in new zealand
for example and they find tattoos on
their lips to be very attractive
so there are some culturally arbitrary
things
but standards of beauty like
cues to youth cues to health
in women clear skin
full lips clear eyes lustrous hair
a small waist hip ratio that is
circumference of the waist relative to
the hips
is acute to youth infertility
and and
acute health uh symmetrical features so
we are a bilaterally bilaterally
symmetrical species but we all have we
all have uh deviations from perfect
symmetry that are due to different
things mutation load
environmental insults diseases during
development and so forth